so don't tell me women don't lie they
lie all the time about different things
I'm not saying men are you know Saints
yeah we know there are men who lie but
we live in a society now where
everyone's comfortable saying there are
men who lie but you're not allowed to
say women lie or you're labeled
misogynist women lie they lie about
their appearance and what happens let me
ask you as a man let's put that picture
up again Delhi can we just put that up
for a second let's say
gosh let's say it was makeup
it's not just makeup I'll tell you that
straight up but let's say it was just
makeup and she managed to transform
herself and you go out to the club and
you're hanging out with that girl on the
left and then she goes takes a shower
and comes out and you see that girl on
the right you don't feel tricked honey I
would feel so tricked I would feel
selfish I'd be like you have to leave
there's an imposter in my house there is
an imposter in the bed and I can't have
it
why not just be yourself women God
why not just be yourself and find a man
who likes you for who you are I know it
sounds like a cliche but man this stuff
men don't like to feel tricked